وفي اولي تعليق له على زياره الى واشنطن
قال لكريم انه لا توجد لدى روسيا توقعات
ايجابيه من زياره الرئيس الاوكراني ولازم
نسكي الى واشنطن اضافه
تغيرا في موقف كيف بشان مفاوضات السلام
بعد زياره للولايات المتحده
لكريم من ان تسليمه اسلحه امريكيه جديده
الى اوكرانيا
ولا يبشره بالخير لاوكرانيا
هذا وقال الكلام ان خطاب الرئيس الروسي
بلازم يفوتنا اليوم خلال الاجتماع مع
قيادات وزاره الدفاع سيكون مهما وضخما
للغايه
في وقت السابق انا بوتين سيرسوا اليوم
اجتماعا موسعا لقياده وزاره الدفاع
لمراجعه نتائج انشطه القوات المسلحه
للاتحاد الروسي للعام الحالي وتحديد مهامي
وخطه العامل المقبل وقلل كريم لاننا وزير
الدفاع سرقه
عن العمل العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
قاده المناطق العسكريه والقوات المسلحه
للاتحاد الرئيسي والرؤساء الهيئه المركزيه
للاداره العسكريه
وممثله الهيئه التنفيذيه الفيدراليه
بان نحو 15,000 مسؤول من القوات المسلحه
الروسيه يشاركون في الحدث عبر الفيديو
معنى الان من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي تطورات
متنوعه ولافته اليوم على الساحه الروسيه
وايضا الاوكرانيه امين في ما يتعلق بزياره
في واشنطن لا توقعات ايجابيه هذا ما يقوله
الكريملين ماذا يتوقع اذا وماذا يتوقع
المراقبون في مصر
[تصفيق]
بالنسبه لروسيا من الواضح ان هذه الزياره
وما تحمله اولا من اشارات سياسيه على ان
واشنطن الماضيه في دعم اوكرانيا سياسيا
وعسكريا ااه يبدو انها لا او ان موسكو لا
تستبشر بهذه الزياره ولا تتوقع اي همم
نتائج ايجابيه على الارض بل بالعكس موسكو
ترى بان تواصل دعم الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا بالسلاح سينعكس السلبيا على
الوضع همم سيجعل مساله الدخول في اي
مفاوضات شبه مستحيله سيعاقد الارض الوضع
على الارض وايضا سيطيل اما همم هذا الصراع
طبعا يهدر هنا في روسيا الى هذه الزياره
على انها اولا لن تغير شيئا على الارض
باعتبار ان الروس عازمون على مواصلات هذه
همم يطلقون عليه على الاقل العمليه
العسكريه همم في اوكرانيا وهناك اشارات
ليس فقط الى الولايات المتحده بل الى باقي
الدول حلف شمال الاطلسيه على ان روسيا
ستستهدف اي نوع من الاسلحه سيتم تقديمها
الى الجانب الاوكراني طبعا هذا ياتي طبعا
بتزامل مع تصريحات مهمه اليوم صدرت عن
رئيسه مجلس الاتحاد الروسي فالنتينا
مترينكو التي قالت بانه لا توجد اي اشارات
على ان روسيا ستدخل في مفاوضات قريبه مع
اوكرانيا خلال الفتره المقبله طبعا عدم
التفاؤل هذا همم يقابله طبعا عمل على على
المستوى العسكري اليوم رئيس نادي ليفربول
الساعه يج- يجتمع مع قاده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في هذا الاجتماع السنوي الذي يتم
من خلاله اولا طرد حصيله عمل القوات
الروسيه في مختلف المناطق خلال العام
وايضا وضع الخطط والاهداف خلال العمل
المقبل الوضع على الارض في اوكرانيا
سيتصدر بكل تاكيد
اجنده هذا الاجتماع اولا من خلال التقرير
الذي سيكلوها وزير الدفاع سيرغي شيكو ثم
من خلال التصريحات المتواليه للقضاء
العسكريين بمن فيهم رئيس هيئه الاركان
ونواب وزير الدفاع الروسي اذن في انتظار
هذا الاجتماع المهم يبدو ان موسكو غير
متفائله بزياره زينيسكي الى واشنطن وتواصل
في المقابل العمل على الاتجاه العسكري في
ما تقول انه همم مواصله عمل لتحقيق اهداف
ما تطلق عليه بالعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كما ذكرت هذا الاجتماع
المهم شكرا جزيلا لك وراسه الجزيره امين